[Music]
my name is swaggy C and I'm from
Bridgeport Connecticut
how does a kid get the name swaggy C
that's easy I thought you say how does
the kid from Fitchburg get on the show
like that's different that's why you see
that just how I dress how I carry myself
my hair song my life started like just
came up with it after Nick Young you
know came up with like a little version
of it and then ran with it
alright so why does swaggy see you want
to do big brother I mean I've been
watching Big Brother since Big Brother 8
and I've been a fan since then for the
last 12 years and I feel like I'd be
really great on it like no in terms of
my physical abilities I have a
photographic memory I'm good with no
people and then relating to them so
audition first time and I got on so hey
not surprised at all at all so would you
consider yourself a superfan or yeah
myself super felt the strength that I've
watched I started with Big Brother a but
I went back and watched every single
season like I studied everything like
even when they told me okay you're you
may have a chance to get on the show I
went back and watched like a lot of
seasons as a player like it was a big
difference so I'm super fair enough I
love the show okay so going into this
game is there a Big Brother vet that
you're kind of taking inspiration from
no I'm going in there and being my game
I love nopal from the last two seasons
and Dan from 10 and 14 but I'm going in
there I'm playing my own game is the new
season there's new players this new
twist is new everything so I can't go in
there trying to emulate Paul and
Daniel's different times and different
players and different twists for his
season so me and myself
yeah it's Big Brother 20 yes the 20th
season everybody needs to get hyper for
it because this is not me the biggest
season out there like whether it's just
like whether they bring vets back or not
whether it's just straight newbies like
it's gonna be the biggest season the
most twists no matter what so everybody
should be excited for it because I know
what I'm moving I'm going to be excited
is there a dream twist you'd like to see
this season yeah no freakin vets let us
play a game or so I don't want to see no
more bets come back but chances are the
vets will come back and I'm ready for
whoever comes back who would you be okay
with coming back
Vanessa Rousso from Big Brother 17 I
feel like she played the game great I
feel like she was loyal to a fault you
know ended up no she
in the final three I don't want to see
Paul back even though he's my favorite
player ever I don't want to see him back
don't want to see Dan bag and everybody
else I don't really care too much so you
know recognize but Vanessa I can see
myself working with Vanessa honestly
okay but you're hoping for back to
basics basics like go back to 16 and 17
were straight newbies and give us a shot
cuz xx I'm gonna want to do a brand year
we're so okay everything comes together
it's the 20th year 20th season okay we
got to do something out of the ordinary
maybe bring some vets back but then at
the end of the day like that's not the
only twist it's more twists involved so
it's like it could be a twist every week
like Big Brother 17 or just one big
twist so I don't know what it is but I'm
I'm expecting anything right now at this
point expect the unexpected I at this
point where this game can get kind of
vicious uh-huh on a scale of let's say
Victoria to dr. will exact Oh 16 16 so
on that scale of Victoria to doctor well
how vicious will you get I wouldn't even
say well I say Dan is probably the most
vicious player ever but I probably use
Dan's point the one thing I won't do
which is I said is swear on Jesus Christ
but other than that I'll do anything in
the game to get me further I don't care
how vicious it is like I'm going to do
whatever it can like what it's like
manipulating people whatever I can do to
get further than again I'm gonna do
nothing is off-limits
all right eye on that prize at the end
nothing is also a Miss no romance isn't
knocking anything that gets me further
I'm doing it I'm with all that noise
alright so if a showmance wasn't your
favorite you jump into a showmance if it
wasn't my favorite but I feel like
what's in my favorite is like
controlling a show man so like people
who are in a showmance me being that
third wheel because I'm always under the
radar like if I'm in a show miss I'm
always gonna be the bigger target like a
limited day like Rachel and Brendan
Brendan went home Jordan and Jeff Jeff
went home let the girl wins the guy goes
home so I'm not trying to be in more
than that like I'll be under that like
I'm trying to be the third wheel so
learn from big brother history got it
you guys you got to play the numbers
going into this game is there anything
that you're gonna keep a secret from
your houseguests the fact that I'm a day
trader and I have a photographic memory
I don't want nobody to know that because
they could use that to my their
advantage saying okay he's good with
numbers he may be good at this
competition let's get him out now I've
got the chance I'm just gonna go in
there and play stupid act like I'm
former college basketball player just as
that and have them you know kind of
theorize whatever they want about me but
I'm keeping that a secret nobody's
knowing that I can remember things that
easily okay is there anything from your
past that you're worried might come out
in terms of so like maybe maybe like the
lifestyle there but other than that no
anything can come out I don't care what
comes out with this ex-girlfriend or or
my family anything come I'm not scared
of my past like brought me here okay
okay you are potentially going away for
three months yeah what are you gonna
miss most about the outside world the
NBA and NB doesn't go on in the summer
but the free agency like I'm giving up
missing LeBrons decision to be on big
boy like that is huge like all that free
agency stuff that's used to me even if I
was saying like all that social media
and the followings and girls text me and
my guy for like the the group chat for
the basketball team like all of that
that can go away I'll see y'all on
October September with like the free
agency the NBA like I need that like no
saying like I something gonna be
thinking about so right that's not a
moment you can recreate I can't recreate
Twitter and the madness when okay LeBron
goes to the Rockets or Chris Paul does I
can't recreate that you phone saying I
gotta come out o this happen well it's
good to know like you know saying like
so that's one thing I miss okay
on the flip side is there anything
you're excited to not have to deal with
for three months a person girls my
ex-girlfriend I don't want to talk to
her only here from where I'd only hear
everybody else I have problems with luck
people have problems I don't hear none
of that I want to go on a show with 15
strangers whoever comes back comes back
and then have fun with them I don't want
to deal with none of the drama in the
outside real world cuz it's fake drama
like if it was bills that's different
but it's people that's fake drama we
don't got time for that like I'm a grown
as a doornail 23 like I know that time
for that so is there a lot of drama back
home yes there's a lot of drama back
home there's a lot I came here at the
perfect time literally like those drama
in my life like I got kidnapped last
week the day before that kidnapped
kidnapped I call it you know how are you
kidnapped they came to my state they
picked me up and took my phone and said
you can't have it no more in took you to
LA oh you were kidnapped yeah oh yeah
you just sound like a random mom you
were just kidding Big Brother kidnapped
me before that it was a lot of drama I'm
glad to get away fighting battle trouble
a lot of girl girl trauma um and just
people in general like old friends like
not talking as much and like just wrong
for no reason I could say that right now
you're in the positive zone illness I'm
back doors then I'm back to negativity I
only had none of that again so what's it
well why are you going to win this
season a big brother because I'm slide
you see and I'm going in there with a
crazy personality that nobody you know
has had before at the end of the day
like people main thing I'm going in
there as cocky and that's the alpha male
I plan on playing the middle scale and
letting everybody know do their little
fights I plan on getting in fights and
being confrontational bottom when I have
a fight every single week and get myself
out of there you know out the house
myself make it to jury survive double
eviction then after that I'll be set for
fine okay I want to be like my goal
right now there's to be the first person
of color to win big brother likes my
only goal to get on the show survive a
jury survive double eviction and then
win the show that's my only goal
everything else other than that is noise
showmance is noise I'd only had none of
it I'm gonna sorta win and that's it you
are I determined that it I don't to hear
nothing else like nothing else isn't
like I see I'm tunnel vision right now I
don't like everything else is just noise
right now at me so
[Music]